I go on vacation I come back and all of
a sudden on the day of the first
presidential debate Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump are now tied let's get
caught up first on the race then I want
to preview the debate I have many many
thoughts I'll tell you what I'm going to
be watching for looking for but let's
not get ahead of ourselves let's first
start with some polling first in a
two-way race we will look at recent
polls and the Real Clear Politics
average here in a two-way race Hillary
Clinton is leading by an average of 2.1
points a cold according of course to the
Real Clear Politics average of recent
polling as you can see here we have a
variety of polls Hillary Clinton leading
in most we have a tie in some and as you
can see in that LA Times USC tracking
poll Trump is plus four I will remind
you if you don't remember how that
tracking poll is done it follows the
same i believe it's three thousand
voters over time and it is different
than all of the other polls and it often
is the only recent poll in which Donald
Trump is winning so according to the
two-way Real Clear Politics average of
recent polling is this race tied well no
not really I mean that there's some
confusion about this and I want to take
a minute just to explain this so we can
all get on the same page people often
will write to me and they'll say David
each individual poll has a margin of
error of about 3 percentage points so if
the average of all recent polls has
anyone leading by fewer than three in
this case it's hillary clinton by 2.1
then statistically it is a tie not
really when you're averaging the polls
you're mitigating the impact of the
individual margin of error of any
individual poll no doubt about it this
is a close race but a a 2.1 percentage
point lead for Hillary Clinton in an
average of all polls is not the same as
an individual poll having a 2
percentage-point lead 3 percentage point
margin of error and thus we can say it
is just tied however some of you will
hear me talk about these polling numbers
and will say but David you're not
including
the two most prominent third-party
candidates libertarian Gary Johnson and
green party candidate Jill Stein well
let's take a look at recent polling done
in a four-way uh method and the Real
Clear Politics average there and it does
hurt Hillary Clinton when you add Gary
Johnson and jill stein as you can see
here with the addition of Johnson &
Stein you see a trump lead in three
recent polls and Hillary Clinton leading
at least in the recent polls dating back
to mid-september uh between one and six
percentage points ahead is Hillary
Clinton so bottom line Hillary Clinton
is maintaining a national lead in the
polling but it is very very close to
tied but this is not a national popular
vote election we do have an electoral
college system so we should also explore
based on state-by-state polling what is
the electoral college map look like and
for that I will show our viewers on
television in YouTube and in all visual
means the map as it stands this morning
on electoral dash vote dot-com and you
will see here in very very clear numbers
that at this point based on State
polling there are no tied States Hillary
Clinton estimated based on current state
polling to come away with 302 electoral
votes Donald Trump 236 electoral votes
and you will note on the map currently
in the important swing state of Ohio
Donald Trump currently leading in the
very important swing state of Florida
Hillary Clinton currently leading and uh
270 is the number that one needs to
become president of the United States
Hillary Clinton currently ahead there
that's where we are and the this is all
to tell you what right what's the point
of reviewing all this the point is this
is a very very close race we had if you
looked at fivethirtyeight.com I'd say
six weeks ago maybe at this point it's
closer to eight if you looked at the
percentages that each candidate had to
win based on a 538 analysis Hill
Clinton reached if not ninety percent I
want to say and eighty-eight percent
chance of winning those numbers have
dropped significantly at one point they
were two to one about 66 2 33 in favor
of Hillary Clinton and as of this
morning when I looked Hillary Clinton
with a roughly fifty nine ish percent
chance to win based on current national
and state polling the first debate could
change it all and that's what I want to
discuss with you now